mics on the line mics in Las Vegas hey
Mike how are you hey I'm doing quite
well how is your morning been so far
better than I deserve what's up
well I'm 18 years old I have no debt I'm
making about eleven hundred a month with
expenses such as rent and my phone bill
and uh you know gas but I'm not sure
where to go from here I decided college
wasn't for me and I'm really not sure
what I'm doing with my money because I
only have 1,200 saved up over this year
of working mm-hmm okay well the biggest
problem that you've got on the personal
financial front is your income is very
very low so the first thing I mind
gravitates to of course you're 18 years
old you're just getting started that's
okay it's not the end of the world here
but the question I would want to ask you
is hey you when you're 38 what do you
want to be doing that makes a hundred
grand a year instead of fourteen
thousand a year understand and how do
you get there what to do one of those
things and I'm with you college is not
for everybody and it's sure not if you
go get a degree in left-handed puppetry
for two hundred fifty thousand dollars
in student loan debt right which would
be called stupid and people do it every
day so you don't do that stuff if you're
gonna go to college for God's sake study
something that can be used but you can
get a degree you know and you can get
like lots of tech degrees I mean you can
get lots of certifications do all kinds
of things without a college degree that
make you very very wealthy so it's very
very possible the question is just you
need to start really start thinking
about you what are you good at do you
like details do you like people you know
are you inclined towards the technology
sector are you inclined towards the art
area what is it that you're you know
that makes you smile and you think gosh
if I did that for 20 years I'd feel like
I've been on vacation the whole time and
then go do a whole bunch of that and get
to become best in the world at that and
train and take classes and read books
and if you read 25 books on a particular
subject by the best minds in the world
you
be one of the leading experts in the
world because nobody knows how to read
anymore
I mean you just go do that so let's work
on the income side of your equation
because you're only met you're making
you know you're basically live in at the
poverty level much again there's no I'm
not shaming you there's no shame in that
I made lesson that myself over time when
I was your age but let's point at
something cuz you'll accidentally become
successful dude that's the big thing
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]